hommes deux femmes ils se sont battus
pendant des mois société et congrès
n'est par l'argent je suis candidat à la
présidence de la république en france et
sous l'occupation financière je veux
entamer une négociation je ne fais pas
pire qu'est ce qui a été fait depuis 25
ans c'est pas une fatalité certains
d'organisation de la société
je ne suis pas l'homme providentiel
arrêtez avec la politique de disneyland
je suis candidat à l'élection
présidentielle je suis candidat pour la
gagner
candidate de la forme départ qui se sont
déroulés de votre confiance
il est 20h vous découvrez ces deux
visages sur votre écran emmanuel macron
crédité de 23 7%
elles ce sont les estimations du premier
tour suivie par marine le pen la
candidate du front national qui
obtiendrait toujours selon nos premières
estimations
ipsos 21 7% des suffrages voilà voilà
pour ces deux candidats qui se détache
en tête regarder les candidats suivants
françois fillon 19,5 à égalité avec jean
luc mélenchon 19,5 donc c'est évidemment
éminemment serrés 6 2% pour benoît hamon
qui enregistre en tout cas dans ces
destinations en mauvais score et 5 %
pour nicolas dupont aignan qui me a
progressé par rapport aux intentions de
vote tout ça peut être évidemment
guillaume revue on va voulant vous
entendre dans quelques instants pour
voir les autres candidats des films et
arnaud on continue on voyait jean
lassalle crédité d'environ 5 % talonné
par philippe poutou 1,2 pour cent
françois asselineau recueillerez 0 8%
des suffrages
nathalie arthaud la candidate de lutte
ouvrière 0 7% et 0,2 pour cent pour
jacques cheminade guillaume petit
d'abord c'est important c'est à vous
qu'on donne la parole ce sont vous avez
bien expliquer la pédagogie